willkommen zur heutigen vorlesungen der
letzten vorlesung im jahr 2021 wollte
geht es um den zweiten teil der ethik
der digitalität und speziellen gedichte
künstliche intelligenz wie immer gibt es
aber erst im rückblick auf die letzte
sitzung der diese sitzung noch ein
bisschen weiter ausführt wir kommen
immer noch der woche danach in den tagen
danach weitere ideen weitere gedanken
die ich dann auch gerne auch mit die
darauf folgenden sitzung einfließen
lassen möchte dann gehen wir über im
zweiten teil auf das eigentliche thema
der heutigen sitzung die ethik der
künstlichen intelligenz und da gibt es
im ausblick am schluss noch auf die
nächste sitzung die da erst im neuen
jahr im jahr 2022 stattfinden wird das
wird dann diese sitzung diese vorlesung
wird der ewige digitalität an einem
weiteren sinne gewidmet zahlen genau
noch einmal möchte ich jetzt zu beginn
die frage thematisieren was ist
eigentlich philosophie der digitalität
oder anders gefragt was ist sie nicht
da möchte ich ein paar thesen dann
einfach formulieren darüber können wir
gerne diskutieren auch unten dann in
youtube wenn's dann online ist also
meine these ist eine philosophie der
digitalität muss ich gleichermaßen von
soziologischen
psychologischen technologischen und
ökonomischen
zugängen zum phänomen der
digitalisierung unterscheiden damit ist
nicht gemeint dass die philosophie ein
alternativer zucker zur digitalisierung
ist also praktisch in der liste hier ein
weiterer punkt das glaube ich nicht die
philosophie die ist noch grundsätzlicher
der philosophische zugang ist noch
grundsätzliche der fundiert die anderen
zugänge die soziologischen
psychologischen technologischen
ökonomischen zugänge in dem die
philosophie der digitalität die jeweils
zugrundeliegenden begriffe digital
analog virtualität realität internet
immersion raumzeit handlung ethik
kritisch reflektieren also die
philosophie der digitalisierung oder
digitalität genau genommen die
reflektiert auf diese begriffe als die
grundlagen die selbst in diesen
disziplinen
nicht eigens thematisch werden das ist
mein verständnis einer philosophie der
digitalität das heißt wir müssen immer
den bezug zu anderen disziplin suchen
vor allem natürlich zur soziologisch und
technologischen aber die philosophie der
digitalität darf daher nicht aufgeben
sondern sie muss sie irgendwie
übersteigen oder auch irgendwie
transzendentale das heißt von der
bedingung der möglichkeit her betrachten
noch ein kurzes kurzen prozess wort zu
meinem verständnis des internets oder
auch die digitalisierung sie haben das
letzte mal darüber geredet da fiel so
das stichwort weiß ich gar nicht ganz
gut findet dass es eine romantisierende
dass ein romantischer begriff der
digitalisierung oder das internet sei
ich denke dass gegen die richtige
richtung aber ich glaube philosophie
sollte nicht im romantisieren zeichne
ich würde sagen der begriff den ich
jetzt hier von internet zu grunde lege
ist ein leicht normativer begriff des
internets dh das sind bestimmte
moralische forderungen mit verbunden
natürlich auch kriterien die gute und
schlechte behandlung von einander
unterscheiden lassen und es ist auch ein
bisschen ein idealisierter begriff so
möchte ich aber die philosophie sollte
sich nicht immer nur mit den fakten wie
sie so sind beschäftigen sondern ein
bisschen weiter ging sonst können wir
gleich die ganzen sachen die sind
disziplin überlassen also die
philosophie muss immer ein bisschen
darüber hinaus gehen aber natürlich
nicht so sehr darüber hinaus dass es
dann zu irgendwelchen wilden
spekulationen das sollte auch nichts
weil es ist immer ein heikles
gleichgewicht was die philosophie hier
finden muss dass muss man immer
aushandeln in der diskussion gerne eben
auch mit den zuschauerinnen zuschauer
eine million teilnehmern dieser
vorlesung wenn man mal wieder ein
bisschen zu weit geht kann man wieder
zurückrufen und so muss man das aus
diskutieren das ist ja auch ein
ursprüngliches anliegen der philosophie
gründe geben und konnte neben für
theesen das ist also meine auffassung
noch mal zu beginn die
blickrichtung auf die thematik und jetzt
möchte ich weil wir jetzt von soziologie
gesprochen haben soziologie der
digitalisierung noch ein buch
hervorheben von manuel castells ist ein
spanischer soziologe er hat ein buch
geschrieben mit dem titel der aufstieg
der netzwerkgesellschaft der ersten
bandes besonders lesenswert wird das
informationszeitalter wirtschaft
gesellschaft kultur
mittlerweile der zweite auflage
entschieden und hier möchte ich mal ein
zitat vorlesen weil das ziemlich gut zu
unseren vorhergehenden vorlesung passt
jetzt aber aus soziologischer
perspektive
er sagt das neue kommunikationssystem
des internets voran transformiert raum
und zeit die fundamentalen dimension des
menschlichen lebens radikal
örtlichkeiten werde nennt körperliche
und verlieren ihre kulturelle
historische und geografische bedeutung
sie werden in funktionalen netzwerk
integriert oder auch in collagen
vorbildern dadurch entsteht ein raum der
ströme anstelle eines raums der ort die
zeit wird im neuen kommunikationssystem
ausradiert wenn vergangenheit gegenwart
und zukunft programmiert werden können
und miteinander in ein und derselben
botschaft zu interagieren
der raum der ströme und die zeitlose
zeit sind die materiellen grundlagen
einer neuen kultur welche die
verschiedenheit der historisch
überkommenen systemen der repräsentation
überschreitet mit der überkommenen
kultur der repräsentation meinte
letztendlich zeichen und bezeichnet das
also schriftzeichen die bedeuten etwas
und kastells argumentiert dafür dass die
kultur der digitalität dass der raum der
ströme die zeitlose zeit dass die nicht
mehr diese trennung von signifikant und
signifikant kennzeichen und bezeichneten
sondern dass das ganze aufgehoben wird
wie genau müssen wir jetzt noch weiter
betrachten interessant finde ich jetzt
hier diese these dass ein raum der
ströme anstelle eines raums der ort
entsteht das ist mir sehr sympathisch
also die räumlichkeit wie ich eben auch
glaube verändert sich vor allem im
internet aber auch in der ganzen sphäre
der virtuellen realität hier hat man
jetzt schon aus soziologischer sicht
eine ganz ähnliche blickrichtung auf
diese finden also ein sehr lesenswertes
buch für diejenigen unter ihnen die sich
ihre soziologisch diesem phänomen der
digitalität zuwenden wollen
jetzt müssen wir noch mal ein bisschen
hier auf das internet eingehen meine
these ist jetzt auch anknüpfend an
kastells ganzen sein phase wir können
nur dann die ethische bedeutung des
internets angemessen stimmt wenn wir es
einen virtuellen handlungsraum verstehen
das hatte ich schon ein paar mal gesagt
diese these und dass jetzt zwei
bedingungen voraus wir müssen virtuelle
realität stärke versteht als leblose
simulation illusion oder fiktion den
illusion und fiktion computer schwache
ethischen mittelpunkt zu das sieht man
an phänomen computerspiele wir gehen
dann einer der nächsten sitzung noch
genau darauf ein computerspieler sind
nur dann problematisch wenn sie nicht
als eine reine simulation perfektion
gefasst werden wir sehen aber schon auch
in bei fiktionen fiktional texten
schriften romanen usw wo es mit
fiktionen zu tun hat da kommen manchmal
auch moralische bewertung ins spiel wenn
bestimmte grenzen überschritten werden
das heißt es ist nicht ganz richtig dass
simulationen oder illusion gar keine
ethische bedeutung haben das haben sie
aber eben nicht so starke ethische
bedeutung wie realitäten die eben keine
großen simulation center und darüber
wird man dann genauer in der sitzung um
computerspiele sprechen auch in der
nächsten sitzung im neuen jahr wir
müssen also vor dem hintergrund des
internets als einem virtuellen
handlungsraum genauer bestimmen was
virtuelle handlungen sind und dabei
spielt insbesondere die raum und zeit
lorig virtuelle realität eine zentrale
bedeutung
jetzt möchte ich noch ein paar beispiele
für virtuelle handlungsräume geben das
ist nicht jetzt erschöpfend soziale
plattformen und kanäle wie facebook
twitter youtube das sind paradigmatische
handlungsräume man kann aber auch das
gesamte internet mit all seinen
informationen und zugangsweisen auf die
information und möglichkeiten des
umgangs mit diesen informationen als
einen ganz großen handlungsraum
bestimmen so gesehen werden kanäle und
plattformen wie facebook twitter und
youtube nur so gebäude oder wohnungen
diesen noch viel größeren handlungsraum
also separate handlungsräume die aber
natürlich teil eines noch größeren
handlungsraum es sind des internets als
solchen ich werde auch in der heutigen
sitzung noch ein bisschen genauer auf
die struktur des internets eingehen weil
es keineswegs so simpel strukturiert ist
das hat viele schichten viele
dimensionen die man auch betrachten muss
aus technologischer hinsicht
soziale plattform sind also keine bloßen
medien die wir rezipieren so ist es eben
teilweise immer noch nicht kommen
nachher auf ein paar statistiken zu
sprechen wo man das nutzerverhalten der
internetnutzerinnen und nutzer genau
sieht nach geordnet nach verschiedenen
bereichen ich glaube aber soziale
plattform wäre nicht hinreichend
bestimmt wenn man sie bloß als medien
der informationsübermittlung betrachten
würde sagen wir sollten den begriff der
information ergänzen durch den begriff
der informationsvermittlung und das ist
eben der handlungs begriff reagieren
durch die es ist soziale plattform wie
rezipieren nicht nur wir stellen auch
information ein das heißt wir sind
sowohl passiv wie als auch aktiv und
diese aktiv aspekt kommt immer wieder zu
kurz in der betrachtung des internets
wenn das internet also ein virtueller
handlungsraum ist dann müssen wir auch
seine struktur schützen und pflegen das
fängt an mit internet protokollen mit
neuen technologien die wir entwickeln
wenn sie mal den neuen spiegel lesen
finden sie da so ein fall dass bei java
wieder eine lücke klaffte die jetzt
gelöst werden muss die geschlossen
werden muss das wird immer mehr zum
anliegen nicht nur einzelne idealistin
und idealisten sind der sollte eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche herausforderung
sein diesen handlungsraum des internet
frei zugänglich und gut
dosierbar und gut behandelbar zu halten
also ich glaube wir müssen wegkommen das
internet nur als so eine wolke sind
irgendwo rum wird irgendwo irgend
welchen servern irgendwelche daten
knoten herrscht und wir sollten sie als
einen handlungsraum verstehen die
internet struktur die uns alltäglich
begleitet und für die wir auch
verantwortung übernehmen müssen wenn wir
sie schon auch nutzen diese struktur so
jetzt möchte ich aber noch genauer
darauf eingehen was eine virtuelle
handlung ist hab ich ja so viel gesagt
im virtuellen handlungsraum dann muss
ich auch was über die virtuelle handlung
sagen und davor natürlich noch was über
eine handlung überhaupt passt es
überhaupt eine handlung das ist jetzt
die frage ich möchte jetzt eine ganz
grobe charakterisierung geben also
handlungen sind auf jeden fall mehr als
bloße ereignisse in der welt wenn wir
zum beispiel eine kaffeetasse
runterfällt oder ich einen reflex habe
im knie oder was auch immer reflex ist
ein gutes beispiel dann ist es ein
ereignis dieser reflex aber gewiss keine
handlung warum ist es keine handlung es
kam keine intentional i tät ins spiel
internationalität bedeutet eine
gerichtet hat des geistes unsere
kognitiven
strukturen die sich zeigen absichten
zielen oder plänen das heißt ich muss es
gewollt haben auch unser wille muss hier
natürlich ins spiel kommt hängt sehr
stark mit internationalität zusammen
donal davidson ein bekannter
analytischer philosoph hat handlungen so
beschrieben ich mach das mal ein
bisschen anders wohnen ist ein agent of
what she does can be described anderen
aspekt that makes it international also
es geht um ein akt um eine das vorgehen
der unter dem gesichtspunkt der absicht
betrachtet werden muss es kommt immer
auf die absicht an ein bloßes ereignis
ist noch keine handlung was ich an
unserem körper vollziehen und es ist
auch nicht damit getan dass nur eine
intensität dazu kommt das ist noch zu
schwach sondern es muss auch eine
rationalität dabei sein es müssen
gründer motive mit dem spiel sein die
fällt fast sprechen strategien und es
muss auch so eine kontrolle dimensionen
kontrolle
kontroll horizont dabei sein dass wir
unsere teil bewegung die dann zur
handlung letztendlich führen dass wir
die koordinieren und dass das ganze
trotz intention ali-t trotz wille nicht
unkontrolliert vor sich geht das wäre
auch keine wirkliche handlung das heißt
eine handlung hat immer eine
einheitliche form es geht um die form
der handlung und dann müssen wir
natürlich auch noch auf die qualität
achten also eine absicht muss in die
handlung übersetzt werden verwirklicht
werden durch unseren willen also der
wille kommt ins spiel bei der
internationalität wenn es um die native
geht habe ein motiv ist auch immer wie
der name schon sagt ein antreiben das
momentan movie morgens an in bewegung
setzen und das wird in der tradition
auch mit dem willen in verbindung
gebracht das heißt wir brauchen auch
eine willens kausalität die dann so was
wie eine kraft gibt um unsere absicht
auch wirklich werden zu lassen und jetzt
kommt auch in der normalen handlung in
der physischen welt von der ich bisher
nur rede so was wie eine bewegung des
körpers natürlich in spiegeln eine
handlung ohne bewegung des körpers ja
schon seltsam dass wird er würde mir
sagen es ist keine handlung werden wir
nur ist bei den willen belassen und nur
bei der intentionen habe ich vielleicht
wunsch aber eine handlung muss wirklich
verwirklicht wir hatten in raum und zeit
und das eben meistens durch bewegung
unseres körpers in raum und zeit sie
sehen schon worauf ich hinauswill dieser
letzte punkt hier der wird bei einer
virtuellen handlung nicht mehr so stark
ins spiel kommen dann auffällig nämlich
jetzt eingehen jetzt frage nämlich
genauer was ist eine virtuelle handlung
wie unterscheidet sich eine virtuelle
handlung von einer physischen handlung
die vollen erklärt hat ich denke wir
müssen klarstellen dass virtuelle
handlungen mehr sind als bloße maus flex
das könnte man jetzt wieder darauf
reduzieren aber das wäre in meinen augen
das säbel werden wir eine physische
handlung gleichsetzen wird mit einem
großen ereignis und blusen reflex
sicherlich vollziehen sich die meisten
virtuellen handlungen oder sehr viele
durch mausklicks aber sie geht aber
nicht auf wir müssen das viel
anspruchsvoller fassen das wäre eine
reduktionistischen sicht virtuelle
handlung auf klose mausklicks zu
reduzieren schließlich kann es in
zukunft und ab jetzt schon andere formen
der befehls übertragung geben
sprachbefehle und alle möglichen
gedanken befehle was auch immer das muss
nicht irgendwie notwendigerweise mit
einem die weiß wie der maus in
verbindung stehen virtuelle handlungen
sind so viel können wir denke ich sagen
tendenziell und körperlich damit möchte
ich jetzt nicht sagen dass dieses
virtuelles objekt auf der sich auch noch
eingeholt dass das irgendwo herum
schwirrt natürlich ist das virtuelles
objekt zurückgebunden an ein raum
zeitlich existierenden körper ganz klar
aber es ist eben damit nicht identisch
das ist meine these sondern so wie auch
das geld die banknote diese 50 euro
schein der wert wie der auf dem papier
reagiert oder wir von dem papier
konstituiert wird so meine these werden
auch wir als virtuelle subjekte
konstituiert von uns sind leiblichen
körper in raum und zeit ohne dass
dazwischen unbedingt eine strenge
identitätskontrolle
und zeit gehen als aspekte nicht so sehr
in die wirtschaft der handlung ein
sicherlich in einer gewissen form aber
doch eher als metadaten das heißt es in
tendenziell äußerlich der rituellen
handlung virtuelle handlung jetzt
positiv bestimmt bestehen so meine these
im herstellen von beziehungen als ihm
verknüpfen in teilen von informationen
im vernetzen und das ist jetzt aber
nicht trivial dass wir bestimmte
informationen im internet verknüpfen die
beziehung setzen sondern dieses
vernetzen das eröffnet ganz neue räume
und das strukturiert auch die art und
weise wie andere und wie wir
informationen wahrnehmen das heißt es
geht auch um die rahmung der information
jetzt kann man aber trotzdem sagen dass
virtuelle handlung aufgrund ihrer
raumzeit logik da wo vollzieht sich
jetzt in die virtuelle handlung an
diesem ort wird uns wieder zu letzten
sitzungen nach oben rechts zählen kann
tobias holl ist das buch über virtuelle
orte ja wo findet jetzt denn die
handlung stadt bei derzeit ist es schon
ein bisschen einfacher kann man sagen so
unser 4 uhr trat diese aktivität auf wir
müssten dann aber schon wieder zeitliche
verzug auch dieser handlung sich
gestaltet und da wäre meine these diese
handlungs vollzog im virtuellen raum
geschieht auf eine ganz andere zeit
weisen in einer ganz anderen zeit lorig
als die physische handel punkte müsste
man jetzt eine phänomenologie der
virtuellen entwickeln also virtuelle
handlungen sind deswegen problematisch
vor allem beide und sehr schwer tun das
virtuelles objekt zu identifizieren das
dafür verantwortlich ist das hat eben
verschiedene gründe ja einfach an die
raumzeit logik das heißt jetzt kann man
die frage stellen nach welchen kriterien
können wir jetzt zb auch moralisch
virtuelle handlung die sich im internet
vollziehen werte meine frage die ich
jetzt an eine virtuelle hantieren
richten würde um sie überhaupt moralisch
bewerten zu können vielleicht auch noch
gar nicht meine strengen sinne
moralischen einfach nur nützlich oder
weniger nützlich wäre die erweitert die
virtuelle handlung den handlungsraum das
heißt verknüpft sie informationen
sinnvoll die internet so dass der
virtuelle handlungsraum sich vergrössern
dass das mehr informationen spiel kommt
die aber mich einfach additiv
eingespeist werden also das internet ist
keine bloße deponie von informationen
sondern informationen müssen sinnvoll
miteinander in beziehung gesetzt werden
ich gebe ein beispiel das ist jetzt aber
wirklich nur vorläufig gibt sicherlich
noch bessere beispiele mitarbeitern
wikipedia als er mit knüpfen am
psychopathischen freien wissen oder auch
kritisch in frage stellen von wissen zum
beispiel verrät peter mitarbeitern
freien netzinfrastrukturen dass also das
internet weiter einen handlungsraum
allein
produktion von freeware wäre sowas
rezeption und bewertung von horizont
erweitern informationen programm und
vielleicht auch aber darüber müsste man
auch genau besprechen und
kommerzialisierung die frage ist
wirklich ob das internet prinzipiell
ganz und kommerzialisiert werden sollte
ich glaube nicht das gehört dazu aber
ich glaube die kommerzialisierung sollte
nicht die hauptstruktur ausmachen das
schränkt wieder unsere freiheit ein mit
rezeption und bewertung meine ich wir
können immer wir haben immer im internet
und zwar viel mehr als dem physischen
raum der physischen handlung die
möglichkeit dinge zu bewerten also ein
feedback zu hinterlassen das muss jetzt
gar nicht groß begründet sein es geht um
eine unmittelbare rückmeldung und eine
viel unmittelbarere reibungsloses
feedback und das ist auch ein weg an
diesem handlungsraum beziehung arbeiten
eine frage die man auch noch eine
virtuelle handlung stellen sollte ist
sie beschränkt die virtuelle handlung
den handlungsraum entkoppelt sie sich
etwa davon oder vernichtet sieht diesen
handlungsraum gar
reduziert sie ihn das ist die frage und
das führt uns zum tat nicht dass ich
heute auch noch ein bisschen eingehen
werde auf fake news auf identitäts
schwindel und auch ein bisschen auf eine
allzu starke kommerzialisierung die mir
auch nicht im sinne einer erweiterung
dieses virtuellen handlungsraum zu
verstehen ist jetzt möchte ich aber
nachdem ich sehr viel schon gesagt habe
zu technischen phänomenen möchte ich
noch ein bisschen was zur geschichte des
internets ihnen nachliefern immer wieder
kam die sprache darauf die muster zu
sagen diese vorlesung ist eben keine
technologische vorlesung über die
geschichte des internets da habe ich gar
nicht die kompetenz dazu ich bin kein
studierter informations wissenschaftler
ich betrachte die geschichte des
internets unter philosophischen
gesichtspunkt auch wenn ich jetzt sehr
viele quantitative informationen geben
werde die sie auch ohne probleme selbst
recherchieren können es soll jetzt nur
zur anregung für die weitere
philosophische diskussion dienen ganz
kurz man sagt ungefähr 1969 ging das
internet hervor aus dem sogenannten
arpanet arpanet ist ein akronym also
eine abkürzung die anfangsbuchstaben
verschiedene würde advanced research
projects agency network es geht also um
ein netzwerk das irgendwie mit mit einer
forschen zu einem forschungsprojekt zu
tun hat was neben advanced ist also
fortschrittlich fortgeschrittene sind 69
das war eine kooperation zwischen dem
massachusetts institute of technology
und dem us-verteidigungsministerium also
wir sehen einerseits hat das internet
was seine wurzeln anbelangt einen
wissenschaftlichen hintergrund
andererseits auch einen politischen oder
sogar militärischen sollten wir nie
vergessen dass die herkunft auch immer
ein bisschen 2schneidig ist die herkunft
ist natürlich sehr komplex man kann
nicht alles auf das arpanet reduzieren
ziel war aber dieses opfer netz eine
topologie als eine virtuelle raum
struktur eines dezentral netzwerks also
hängt nicht alles an einem server seien
die server werden unabhängig voneinander
und das ist die kunst struktur des
internets das dezentrale seit 1989
findet eine kommerzialisierung des world
wide webs so hat man seit 1989 seien
genannt www und sie kennen sicherlich
tim berners-lee und das crn koste
européen pour la recherche nucléaire als
die atomforschung in genf mit ein
bisschen zweischneidigen atomforschung
das hat dieses world wide web begründet
im sinne der idee des hyper textes und
dieser begründer dieses www hat gesagt
the world wide web so wide area hyper
media information retrieval initiative
sailing to give universe alexis taylor
universe of dogs hier ist also ganz
wichtig eine hyper medium als es nicht
nur ein medium sind ist es etwas was
verschiedene medien verbindet oder die
grundlage ist hyper medium finde ich
schon sehr treffend für das internet ich
gehe eben noch einen schritt weiter und
sagt andere sachen
und hier sagte auch noch wichtig ein
universal access also es geht hier um
das universale um die ganze zeit hier
ist natürlich die idee des dezentralen
netzwerks auf die spitze getrieben die
topologie des world wide webs ist die
welt und nicht nur irgendwie dass emma
rikki und das
us-verteidigungsministerium also hier
finden wir eine entgrenzung des
internets und die jedenfalls sehr
idealistisch gedacht ist die aber eben
auch noch in diesem zitat recht
beschränkt ist eben nur auf retriever
also letztendlich eine passive rolle wir
besorgen und wir ziehen die
informationen aus dem netz natürlich
wäre das jetzt so einfach gesagt dass
nur als ein pazifistisches
unternehmen zu charakterisieren wir
haben ja in einer der vergangenen
sitzungen gesehen in dem ich überhaupt
information bekomme oder um sie zu
bekommen muss ich erst suchen nach den
informationen und dieses suchen ist
natürlich kein passiver akt da suchen
ist eine aktivität und insofern kann man
schon sagen dass suchen selbst ist auch
eine handlung im virtuellen raum des
internets
das habe ich natürlich alles aus
wikipedia können sie alles in ruhe
nachlesen jetzt möchte hier noch auch
ein bild aus wikipedia vorstellen dass
es sehr interessant das ist eine
veranschaulichung des internets und zwar
mit bezug auf seine
sendungen auf seine
auch länderspezifischen endungen ich
zitiere aus wikipedia teile einer karte
des internets basierend auf daten von
opticon tag ein bisschen veraltet 15
januar 2005 jede linie also jede linie
drin dieses lied beschreibt zwei
knotenpunkte welche zwei ip adressen
repräsentieren die länge der linien
beschreibt die verzögerung zwischen
quoten also hat man so ein bisschen
räumlichkeit und zeitlichkeit in dieses
netz hinein gebracht die linien sind
farblich entsprechend der adress
bereiche gekennzeichnet dunkelblau
endung net kanada ist grün kommt mit gas
uk japan china taiwan ich glaube dass
australien deutschland marc inter
vereinigte ok kindern italien polen
polen und frankreich gold wahrscheinlich
brasilien korea und niederlande weiß
unbekannten wir sehen hier also eine
punkte farbliche mischung das ist der
versuch mit hilfe von grafiken die auch
sich räumlich erstreckten farblich sind
die sehr sehr komplex ist des internets
abzubiegen finde ich wirklich sehr sehr
interessant wenn man hier rein suchen
den 1 die teilbereiche unten dann sieht
man hier die ganzen ip adressen die
verbindung von unterschiedlicher längen
ja jetzt möchte ich ein bisschen
konkreter werden ein paar quantitative
informationen geben die werden immer
qualitativ als philosophin und vier
songs interpretieren müssen und zwar die
der internetzugang einiger länder in
europa auch wieder aus wikipedia hat
stand 2012 ich war mir ganz oben an
island 95 prozent aller haushalte haben
internetzugang niederlande luxemburg
norwegen dänemark und deutschland ist
ganz okay so im mittelfeld jetzt gehen
wir ans ende nord mazedonien bulgarien
rumänien wir sehen also auf jeden fall
geografisch ein gefälle vielleicht ein
nord-süd-gefälle müsste man sich jetzt
genauer anschauen und das sollte jetzt
auch politisch zu denken geben dass man
bestimmte regionen nicht strukturell
benachteiligt durch
internetzugängen wenn das internet
behandlungsraum ist dann haben diese
nationen keine freiheit sich im
virtuellen raum zu betätigen das wäre
als würde man ihnen die infrastruktur
nicht ermöglichen also hier ist denke
ich noch viel zu tun auf europäischer
ebene
wieder quelle wikipedia jetzt möchte ich
noch ein bisschen was alte sagt zum
download bezeichnet jetzt nicht dass da
oben sind atmet ist einfach die
beschreibung die diese grafik insgesamt
hat quelle pearson.de es gibt das so
genannte klier web das ist dasjenige die
informationen die sie die index index
indexiert sind die sie also durch
suchmaschinen sich anschauen können wie
zum beispiel google findet das kläre die
mit die bildlichkeit ist auch
interessant die metapher des eisbergs
finde ich sehr treffen klären wird mit
visuellen mit davon glaube die sonne
jetzt alles klar strukturiert
sind mit haltung und jetzt gehen wir mal
unten da gibt es die prep das sind nicht
indexierte seiten die finden wir nicht
über suchmaschinen zumindest nicht vor
allem google wahrscheinlich nicht und
google hat ja sehr viele nutzerinnen und
nutzer und dann gibt es hier ganz unten
ganz unten nicht die spitze sein und
irgendwann boden des eisbergs da
schwimmen ein paar haifische runter
wird's gefährlich da wird auch sehr
dunkel da komme ich dann nur rein hier
unten dass daten mit dem tor browser und
eine online adresse und auch mit
einladungen also hier wird der zugang
schon mal sehr also relativ komplex ja
ich sage es ist nicht direkt
benutzerfreundlich in das tal zu kommen
wie man ins klärwerk kommen nur soviel
also hier sieht man schon allein durch
die veränderte zugangs weise wird der
handlungsraum beschränkt wird selektiert
und das halte ich schon aufgrund seiner
struktur für moralisch problematisch wir
müssen jetzt gar nicht genau auf das
parkett eingehen was dort alles vor sich
geht das kann man an anderen orten
weiter lesen wie geht es einfach nur um
diese komplexe struktur also internet
ist nicht gleich internet immer die
frage von was reden wir wir reden jetzt
die meistens von diesem klima aber wir
sollten nicht vergessen dass es auch
noch eine andere seite des internets
gibt die eben auch aus handlungs
theoretischen ethischer sicht hoch
problematisch ist wir sollten immer ein
sehr differenziertes bild vom internet
unseren philosophischen überlegungen
zugrunde legen ich möchte ich noch ein
paar weitere statistik bringt hier vom
oxford internet institute der university
of oxford das sind jetzt die
nutzerzahlen die über diesen tor browser
ins bett gehen und zwar immer pro
100.000 ja und hier sieht man ganz
interessant das konzentrierte schon auf
europa und viele nationen auch im
asiatischen bereich sind gar nicht so
repräsentiert afrika überhaupt nicht
hier sieht man wieder eine räumliche
verordnung wird hier vorgenommen das
heißt sicherlich kann man auch den
virtuellen handlung räumlich sich
vorstellen aber er ist doch ziemlich
abstrakt hier sieht man also doch dass
ein ungleichgewicht herrscht in der
nutzung des internets und vor allem eben
auch des tages wenn man das ganze mal
vom tag mit aufziehen und nicht immer
nur vom kreml finde ich auch eine ganz
interessante
herangehensweise jetzt punkt eines
meiner lieblingsprojekte das ist so ein
gegenentwurf zur tat nicht dass das so
genannte internet greift das feld grad
seinen 25 geburtstag
und dieses internet hat eine ganz
interessante suchfunktion stichwort
wieder suchen die sogenannte wayback
machine und diese rakeback maschinen
umfasst ein archiv auf 635 milliarden
webseiten die über die zeit gespeichert
worden und der witz dieser wayback
machine kann ich ihnen sehr empfehlen
fall ist nicht genutzt nutzen sie es mal
geben sie markieren dieses adressfeld
eine beliebige domain ein dann werden
sie ganz verschiedene vergangene
schnappschüsse snapshots wie es hier
heißt dieser seite entdecken
und zwar nehmen wir jetzt mal lmu
punkt.de seines poliers unter ludwig
maximilians universität münchen ist wenn
ich jetzt lmu de eingeben diese way back
maschinen sehe ich hier ein zeitstrahl
das führt uns wieder zur mittagszeit
reihen
und zwar hier würde ich sagen ist die
zeitreihe die bi reihen also hier sieht
man was war früher war es war später
aber das jetzt spielt hier nicht so eine
direkte rolle ist die beere wir sehen
hier sind alle zeitpunkt oder zumindest
viele präsident ist immer präsent und
wir können jetzt hier mal ganz vor
springen sondern das frühjahr 2000 und
diesmal die erste web page stellen
anschauen und das sieht dann so aus hier
unten noch mindestens acht 600 sie sehen
allein auch das seitenverhältnis ist
noch 3 2 also nicht das moderne was wir
jetzt haben also noch recht bescheiden
der witz ist der status dieser dieses
snapshots der ist jetzt nicht mehr
wirklich zeitlich zu verstehen ich sehe
dieser seite schon an dass sie alt ist
das so aber sie ist prinzipiell von
ihrer darstellung heer von ihrer
aufbereitung nicht älter als die
aktuelle zeit das ist viel zeit
vergangen aber ich kann es nicht
materiell fassen wie zum beispiel von
einem buch was jetzt 20 jahre alt ist
die buch sehe ich es an und zwar nicht
nur weil damals eine andere mode
herrscht das buch zu drucken eines ist
materiell auch durch die zeit gegangen
und das kann man jetzt hier nicht mehr
sagen bei dieser seite das heißt da
scheint jetzt eine andere zeit logik
zugrunde zu liegen die auf die cd von
meta hinzuweisen scheinen dh jede
vergangenen zeitpunkt wieder uns
repräsentieren präsent machen das ist
eine ub präsenz der internet information
die eben dieses internet ermöglicht
gehen wir noch einen schritt weiter es
wird noch interessanter jetzt gehen wir
mal hier auf die seite des philosophie
départements die menschen dann kommen
wir auf dieses schicke bild das ist
glaube ich so 2002 also hier sehr
stylisch ja aber sieht es könnte auch
heute noch auf einer webpage sein gibt
es bestimmt auch noch an man sieht das
ist in die jahre gekommen
trotzdem hat es nicht diese unterliegt
das nicht dieser zeit logik wie andere
dinge ich kann es wieder repräsentieren
es ist nicht in der art verschwunden
oder der bereich nicht mehr
präsentierbar ist lässt sich durch das
arc halt immer wieder in die gegenwart
ziehen das scheint mir so ein punkt für
diese zahl der zeit dass sein die die
virtuelle
qualität des internets auszeichnet
schauen sie mal nach sehr sehr
interessant was da noch alles archiviert
wurde ja ich möchte ein paar weitere
statistiken bringen natürlich jetzt nur
quantitativ gehen wir auf die anzahl der
internetnutzer im millionen pro jahr
hier sehen wir quelle statista.com hier
sehen wir die anzahl nimmt immer mehr zu
im jahr 2001 an sich sind es knapp fünf
milliarden mit zerrinnen muss sich
gewaltig dieser anstieg nach und es wird
sicherlich eben also weitergehen als
eine gewaltige datenbasis wir können
auch die verbindungsgeschwindigkeit uns
mal anschauen die durchschnittliche
verbindungsgeschwindigkeit bei
festnetzanschlüssen im oktober 2021
medianwert in megabits pro sekunde
wir sehen ganz oben singapur mit 190
megabits und doch ziemlich abgeschlagen
deutschland mit immerhin 64 megabits pro
sekunde das sind 8 megabyte pro sekunde
das ist eigentlich ganz okay acht
megabyte aber schauen sie mal hier oben
singapur hat dreimal so viel wie
deutschland also nicht nur der zugang
überhaupt zum internet ist ein problem
wie viele europäische länder ist einfach
noch nicht haben sondern auch die
geschwindigkeit diesen faktor der den
virtuell handlungsraum zumindest
fundiert der virtuelle handlungsraum des
internets geht nicht auf in der
internetgeschwindigkeit aber er hängt
damit doch auch irgendwie zusammen eher
beschränkt uns im handlungsspielraum
wenn ich informationen nicht schnell
genug um erhalt oder nicht schnell genug
interagieren kann es ist so als sei ich
irgendwie gehemmt als würde ich
beschränkt in meiner freiheit des
virtuellen handlungsraum also hoch
interessant wir sehen die asiatischen
länder sind ganz vorne in chile hat mich
überrascht finde ich sehr spannend usa
hat mich auch überrascht ich hätte
gedacht usa so ein bisschen geringer
aber wirklich hoch interessant zu sehen
in asien ist das ganze viel viel
schneller und europa hängt ein bisschen
hinterher
ist ein wichtiger faktor
noch kurz zum schluss das
nutzerverhalten finde ich ganz
interessant wenn wir jetzt sagen es geht
um die virtuelle virtuelle realität des
handlungsrahmens erfolgen was für
aktivitäten liegen denn diesen
handlungsraum zu kunden sprich was tun
denn die nutzer nutzer im virtuellen
raum das internet und es ist ziemlich
banal es ist zehnten empfang von e mails
das machen 90 prozent aller befragten
suchen nach informationen über waren und
dienstleistungen einmal hin suchen
suchen ist ja jetzt nicht nur was passt
versuchen ist eine aktivität gelesen von
online zeitschriften suche wieder also
suche scheint doch sehr wichtig dass
sein telefonieren webcam und hier eben
recht viel rezept ivi tät musik hören
uns erwartet was mir jetzt hier noch
fehlt ist
computerspiele online computerspiele das
wird sicherlich zunehmen und ich glaube
auch dass arbeiten immer mehr zunehmen
wird ja das kommt jetzt hier nämlich gar
nicht so richtig vor das wäre vielleicht
ihr hier telefonieren videotelefonate
hat die arbeit im wirtschaftsraum wird
zunehmend durch nicht zuletzt durch die
kommune krise wie wir sie gerade noch
erleben das finde ich ganz interessant
wie der quelle statista.com dann hatte
ich schon mal kurz darauf hingewiesen
alles um die das nutzerverhalten im takt
gegen diese europäische karte wo man
gesehen hat in zentraleuropa es häufiger
in asien sehr gering die gans im oxford
internet institute und darauf möchte ich
sie auch noch hinweisen das ist also
wirklich ein eigenes institut der oxford
university der sich nur mit dem internet
beschäftigt jetzt nicht nur aus
philosophischer perspektive sondern aus
ganz verschiedenen bereichen
ökonomie
kulturpolitik erziehung ethik hier ist
luciano für ideen ich schon ein paar mal
erwähnt hatte angesiedelt geografie
ungerechtigkeit
informations herrschaft und sicherheit
und soziale data seitz ja also hier
sehen wir ganz interessante punkte ja
jetzt kann man weiter fragen ich komme
gleich auf die ganzen fragen die sie
haben kann man dann gleich in der
diskussion dann später eingehen jetzt
ist die frage was ist ein virtuelles
subjekt eigentlich das heißt wie
unterscheidet sich ein physisches von
einem virtuellen zug liegt
ein virtuelles subjekt interagiert
körperlos auch wenn es durch einen
lebendigen charakter fungiert ist das
heißt wir geistern da nicht irgendwie
rom im virtuellen raum ist natürlich
sitzen oder stehen irgendwo das ist ganz
klar aber so meine these die handlung
die mit virtuellen raum vollziehen die
geht nicht mehr nur darin auf dass wir
beschreiben was damit unserem körper
vorgeht wenn wir diese handlungen
virtuell doppelt sie natürlich brauchen
wir den körper dazu aber die handlung
lässt sich nicht darauf reduzieren das
wäre in meinen augen ein reduktionismus
das kann man sich fragen das führt auf
das eigentliche thema und zur heutigen
vorlesung ist künstliche intelligenz
einig ein subjekt oder ein akteur eine
akteurin ja das müssen wir uns gleich
noch genauer anschauen diese frage
interessant ist auch das virtuelle
objekte oder agenten im virtuellen
handlungsraum das internet in
namentlicher anonyme oder auch
pseudonyme form existieren können es
heißt die präsentationsform die
erkennungsmerkmale sind nicht so gegeben
wie sie in der physischen welt sind ich
kann nicht gleich sehen wer das jetzt
ist ich kann sicherlich schon von
welcher ip-adresse ist diese nutzern
diese nutzer jetzt daran kann aber sein
da steckt ein virtual private network
dahinter die ip-adresse ist gar nicht
die richtige es gibt ganz verschiedene
möglichkeiten identität zu verschleiern
das geht natürlich auch in der
physischen welt ganz klar aber lagen
nicht so leicht und das scheint mir
nicht nur ein quantitativer unterschied
zu sein seien qualitativ ein virtuelles
objekt so kann man die zusammenfassen
hat problematische identitäts
bedingungen worin besteht denn jetzt die
identität dieses wird für das objekt
oder sein
ich denke man kann es definieren wenn
bei uns auch den handlungs begriff
anschauen durch seine intention ali t
das heißt die identität des virtuellen
subjekts können wir rekonstruieren
vielleicht nicht perfekt aber doch
entscheiden durch seine suchanfragen
seine vernetzung und teilungen von
informationen aber auch durch die
vorlieben die individuellen vorlieben
die wahl der avatare und auch pseudonyme
als auch die fiktionen die durch den
virtuellen raum gepflegt werden auch die
lassen rückschlüsse zu auf das
virtuelles objekt das heißt es gibt
erkennungsmerkmale die rückschlüsse auf
die identität des virtuellen zu klicks
lassen in meinen augen ist es vor allem
die suchen du bist das was du suchst im
internet haben ja so und jetzt kommen
wir nach diesem ganzen pre pre
militärischen untersuchungen kommen wir
jetzt auf die ethik der künstliche
intelligenz zu sprechen das heißt wir
müssen voraussetzen wenn wir uns dem
thema widmen ob künstliche intelligenz
ein überhaupt ein subjekt ist und
künstliche intelligenz überhaupt handeln
kann wenn wir es immer in analogie zum
virtuellen akteur verstehen wenn wir uns
fragen ob künstliche intelligenz
virtuelle akteurinnen oder akteuren sind
besitzt künstliche intelligenz
internationalität ist künstliche
intelligenz autonom servieren wir
glauben es zu sein das sind also die
fragen die wir an künstlichen stellen
sollten und wie sollten wir jetzt kann
ich verstehen es gibt ganz verschiedene
möglichkeiten keine technik mit
technologie sein könnte die ganz kleinen
werkzeugen instrument sein das kann ein
medium sein das kann objekt oder
maschine seien so wird häufig von
künstlicher intelligenz geschrieben
gesprochen sind irgendwelche machines
die da irgendwas intelligentes tun wir
können weitergehen wir können sagen kann
ihm als subjekt zu stehen sie können
auch karlsplatz es verstehen oder als
doktor ich sag schon vorweg mir schwer
ist sympathisch die letzten zwei
beschreibungen formen die sind mehr am
sympathischsten
und zwar deswegen mich am ende noch
heute zeigen werde weil kali immer mehr
verwoben wird mit unseren intentionen
das heißt wir sollten ki nicht verstehen
als was separates was unabhängig von uns
existiert sondern es hängt ganz eng die
calli end ganz eng mit uns auf ganz
verschiedene weisen zusammen auch mit
unserer intensität ich glaube also dass
die ersten viel zu reduktionistischen
sind um sie wirklich philosophisch
betrachten zu können auch
reduktionistischen das hier wiederum ist
zu stark
und das hier scheint mir die lösung zu
sein aber darüber könne man schließt
auch diskutieren ich bringe ja nochmal
vier problematische tendenzen bezüglich
kann zudem uns abgrenzen sollten in
meinen augen ideologisierung das hat
sich auch zu beginn der vorlesung schon
gesagt keine transformers tisch vor
theologisches silicon valley das bringt
uns nicht viel bei der frage nach
künstlicher intelligenz weil immer dann
die antwort sein wird ja aber in 50
jahren wird das sein da werden sie die
weltherrschaft unternehmen das bringt
mir nichts ich möchte es jetzt wissen
ich möchte im prinzip ist nicht
irgendwas was mal sein kann da auch
nicht auch die anthropomorphe sierung
verkehr und für robotik halte ich für
nicht adäquat was ist denn ein roboter
wenn er auf künstliche intelligenz
basteln das ist ein system ein
neuronales netzwerk was eben noch eine
augenhöhle bekommt aber die außenhülle
ist völlig äußerlich darin geht er ab
geht die künstlichen die begins nicht
auf das heißt wir müssen den prozess
eines neuronalen netz stehen und das ist
eben ein prozess und kein objekt auch
kein roboter das halte ich für irre
führen und dann banalisierung von cani
als bloßes wischen gesagt halte ich die
reduktion genauso natürlich auch die
thematisierung der calvi das hält wieder
irgendwie die ideologisierung zusammen
das lied kam nie zu sehr ich glaube k s
etwas viel banaler ist aus ihrer sicht
das einfach über unsere lebenswelt immer
mehr eingang befindet und mit dem wir
uns einfach auseinander setzen müssen
aber nicht im sinne von spekulationen
zum inszeniert von lebens wirklich
realität und alltagsrealität und wie
genau das werde ich gleich noch mehr
leute das heißt es gibt jetzt neuerdings
ein oxford handbook auf fx auf das kann
ich ihnen sehr empfehlen und da lese ich
jetzt mal einen aufsatz ein zitat aus
einem aufsatz und der einheit vor sagt
bekommen approach ist may not diese
fische primarily die transformation
nature
science engineering and human touch die
gewöhnlichen die häufigsten alltäglichen
ernährung an künstliche kennst die
könnten nicht hinreichend zeit um
künstliche intelligenzen ihrer ethischen
bewertung zu fassen bevor es erste titel
concessions wiebels possibility
intentions autonomie virtual wide
monster des treffens in christa lang
model strong
exklusiv vom examples of university in
triesen behavior of the
fixer cording riebel dieses konzept
schon tools
also bisher hat man einfach nur
überkommene konzepte die aus der
menschlichen ethik standen einfach eins
zu eins angewendet auf günstig tickets
auch die fische intelligence sowie die
autoren will challenge birdies concepts
and more sfs beginnt die gäste brocken
auf continued human koexistenz mit
alternate impresario intelligence das
heißt es geht darum dass wir es hier um
eine vision eine koexistenz von
menschlicher intelligenz und künstliche
intelligenz die ethik der künstlichen
intelligenz sollte sich um die
koexistenz von beiden intelligenz formen
tränen wird ist es
in
which were quite riesen gold fx von
lenny das ist korrekt more the pages
oder bin jede tour etwas die fx auf
interviews die autoren sind hier sehr
provokativ die sagen das aufkommen von
künstlerresidenz wird eine
herausforderung für unsere bisher
ethischen begriffe seien die wir schon
seit tausenden von jahren haben zu
denken ist hier eben an aristoteles und
auch vielleicht ein bisschen platt dann
aber zumindest aristoteles für zirka
2300 jahren ja diese begriffe werden
sich enger ich selbst stimme dem sehr zu
man muss jetzt allerdings schauen wir
genauer sie sich ändern das macht der
autor dann auch aber wir wollen jetzt
hier noch eigene wege finden dass er
geht noch ein bisschen weiter der
challenges fort und fünf major calgarys
erstens konzept anbieten zweitens ist er
ist drittens implementing schien fx1
damit die chance auf sein ticket
exploration and prediction und fünf
oppositionelle system fxr porsches all
das geht ja zunächst mal um die
begriffliche unklarheit das hat er schon
erwähnt im verhalten zutat der es gibt
ein problem die menschlichen ethischen
begriffe die uns menschen betreffen auf
künstliche intelligenz eins zu eins
anzuwenden das scheint nicht mehr ganz
adäquates seite müssen wir immer schon
bb die risiken abwägen die auch
natürlich mit künstlicher intelligenz
einhergehen wie wir maschine ticken
implementieren unsere ethik geben nur
sich auf die maschine richten müssen
natürlich auch schon welche
psychologischen probleme sie stellen
wenn künstliche intelligenz in mehr
wissen generiert dem wir gar nicht
erfolgen können wir nicht herr werden
können und wir müssen schauen welche
ethischen
annäherungen welche ethischen begriffe
wir überhaupt für dieses phänomen
verwenden da gibt es ganz verschiedene
ethischen politische systeme dafür
geeignet sein könnten weiterlesen vor
kurzem das kannst du dat report liu
streams in der viele intelligente agent
und autonomes agent taken into account
what we thought about the face of com -
auf die streams
dezember die fans lichtenberg mit
schlecks blade ende händel zins motto
news agency kleider autonomes no angels
vor der fleischerei kreis intelligence
agency
intelligent noch agence hier ist ein
bezug auf das lichtenberg messer licht
und bleibt ein berühmter aphoristiker
um 1800 der hat ein begriff eines
messers geprägt dem eine klinge fehlt
und dass auch keine kein griff hat ja
wenn das eben fehlt dann ist es kein
wasser mehr
und so sagte eben auch ist es mit dem
begriff autonome agent mit blick auf die
künstliche intelligenz weder ist könnte
die autonom noch ist sie ein magnet an
akteur noch intelligent und charakter
es sind einfach zwei begriffe die
zusammen sinn ergeben aber nicht
angewendet auf künstliche intelligenz
zumindest die vor mit denen wir es
momentan zu tun haben weiteres detail
continues to grow importance
verständnis und michael o'leary swiss
village auf description of the match
gehören bei uns auf predigt schon zins
der kampf von data intensiv mathematiker
mordes zu einer import sharons verzicht
auf fx auf sie hat ihr einem ethik der
künstliche intelligenz blick ist how ist
in krisen used to establish scientific
facts and well thought that can be ready
explain the public on some cases even to
expand ist beim service wie focus on
ways and create the future of scientific
research für forschung zur zertifikat
ist ein problem sagt julia feature of
cambridge
in terms of corrections update
dokumente will increase in gent human
scientific understanding also es geht
einfach hier und das problem dass das
wissen durch künstliche intelligenz
überproportional wächst und wir ihm
nicht mehr ganz herr werden können also
wie gehen wir mit dieser asymmetrie auch
in informations bewältigen das finde ich
alles sehr sehr wichtige punkte die ihr
auch sehr kritisch entwickelt werden
jetzt möchte ich noch zum abschluss ein
paar eigene thesen formulieren ausgang
an diese sehr zutreffende überlegung aus
diesen ops erscheint box office of wire
ich denke müssen festhalten dass
künstliche intelligenz immer mehr teil
unserer lebenswelt das oxford ein buch
spricht von der koexistenz
ich glaube das müssen wir sehr ernst
aber mir scheint der begriff der
menschen erschienen interaktion dafür
nicht mehr angemessen zu sein der setzt
nämlich voraus dass da ein mensch ist
und da es eine maschine also das subjekt
objekt dieses subjekt objekt schema ich
glaube das wird dieser lebensweltlichen
realität die man weniger gerecht wenn ki
immer mehr eingang in unser leben findet
nahtlos eingang deswegen sollten wir die
nicht im sinne eines subjekts objekts
verstehen nicht als erschien sondern als
prozess und intelligenz leistung sollten
es also tatsächlich von dem von dem
betrachten was da passiert also von den
eigenen eigentlichen operationen weniger
von dem was dahinter steht hinter der
kooperation
da bin ich jetzt mal ganz
positivistische diese intelligenz lage
es zulässt sich um zu leben zu
integrieren und mit anderen menschlichen
oper hat zu vernetzen das scheint mir
ganz wichtig zu sein mensch maschine
interaktion ist keine vernetzung in
diesem sinne von verschiedenen
intelligenz leistung die die künstliche
intelligenz sollte sich gemessen an der
lebenswelt integration und vernetzung
also welche rolle diese künstlich
eleganz beide erweiterungen und
vernetzung von informationen ihrer hat
die immer natürlich von uns abhängig ist
und jetzt kann man sich verträgt
künstliche intelligenz zu erweiterung
des virtuellen raumes bei das soll
glaube ich dir sollte die leitfrage
seien bei einer ethischen betrachtung
wird der virtuelle handlungsraum
erweitert wird er klar also nicht nur
größer sind des additiven sonst würde
das strukturierte würde übersichtlich
haben wir mehr orientierung ich hatte in
der letzten sitzung gesagt eine
virtuelle handlung hat es immer auch mit
orientierung zu tun also hilft und
künstliche intelligenz den virtuellen
handlungsraum orgel tier baarer zu
machen und ich glaube das kann es nicht
aber nicht notwendigerweise hier setzt
sagen die ethische bewertung an
deswegen sind künstliche neuronale netze
die ich jetzt als paradigmatisch für
kunst und die djs nehme
bloße maschinen oder sogar subjekte weil
wir menschen immer in deren leistung
eingehen nämlich durch die datenbasis
die jedem vernünftigen plötzlich
neuronalen netz zugrunde liegen muss
irgendwas begonnen werden die beginne
ich aus der puren luft heraus und das
heißt wir selbst gehen ihnen sie ein
diese intelligenz leistung wenn auch
nicht mehr identifizierbar ja sie kennen
bestimmt fälle wo man dann fragt ja was
für ein bild ist jetzt dass das mit
künstlicher intelligenz erstellt wurde
da kann könnten wir derzeit aber eben
nicht mehr so dass man sagt ihr das ist
mal wird die datenbasis auf eine ganz
interessante weise transformiert dass
man nicht mehr heraus damit dividieren
kann was jetzt davon uns drin ist das
ist eine interessante erkenntnis die mir
mein kollege arno schubach mal gesagt
hat im rahmen eines seminars über kg der
sich mit ihm leiterin marie oben rechts
auf den link rhein zu diesem seminar das
heißt es ist nicht mehr so leicht
identifizierbar menschliche leistung und
khalil leistung interferieren vielmehr
finde dass es gibt eine wechselwirkung
zwischen behalten und sie integrieren
auf eine bestimmte weise nämlich inter
objektiv das möchte ich auch noch
erklären inter objektivität hatte ich
auch in den vergangenen sitzungen
gemacht die bedeutet ein kontext von
gründen und zielen da steht also
intention ali täterin der durch cani
weiter vernetzt und verstärkt das
internet wird weniger zu einem netz von
informationen wie man es heute
überwiegend noch sieht in der tradition
des www von 189 sondern es wird immer
mehr zu einem netz begründet das heißt
er kann uns helfen unsere
internationalität zu erweitern und da
auch schritt wird uns fast abzunehmen
dennoch müssen künstliche neuronale
netze immer von außen ein ziel
vorgesetzt bekommen künstliche
intelligenz meine these wird nie in der
lage sein sondern sich selbst aus sich
eigene ziele zu setzen es braucht immer
irgendwelche ziele vorgegeben werden
dann kann aber diese intelligenz
leistung sehr sehr treffend im solche
erweiterung des virtuellen
handlungsrahmens mit unseren zielen eine
eingesetzt werden das heißt die
verantwortungs zuschreibung wird durch
keine immer schwieriger ich hatte das
problem der problematischen
identifizierbarkeit schon erwähnt wer
trägt die verantwortung für ein
künstliches neo nahles netz saubermann
autonom fahren der hersteller also tesla
der nutzer die nutzerin die das auto
fährt was natürlich auch lernt durch das
nutzerverhalten oder die ki selbst ich
glaube die frage ist falsch gestellt wir
können das nicht so leicht auseinander
dividieren
wir sollten das ganze als ein gemeinsam
komplexes phänomen verstehen wo wir als
nutzer immer auch mit eingehen das heißt
virtuelle handlung sind viel vernetzter
als es unsere physischen handlungen sind
alles steht mit allen prinzipiell in
verbindung und zwar auf eine solche
komplexe weise dass wir es gar nicht
mehr ist emissions 10 nachverfolgen
können deswegen ist auch die frage nach
der verantwortung beschreibung von kann
ihn auch komplex haben und hier findet
eine übergangs von der individuellen
person zu kollektiven personen statt die
inter objektiv interagiert kollektive
person kennen wir auch durch zb staaten
oder auch unternehmen juristische
personen manche sind kann man als
kollektive person ansehen das heißt wenn
es hier um handlungen geht die durch
ganz verschiedene teil agenten
physischer art konstituiert werden im
virtuellen raum dann sollte man zum
militär von kollektiven personen
sprechen als von individuellen personen
also der begriff der kollektiven person
wird durch den virtuellen handlungsraum
des inhalts immer bedeutender werde ja
das war jetzt meine thesen ich gebe noch
einen kurzen ausblick zur nächsten
sitzung im neuen jahr da wird es um die
ethik der digitalität gehen und zwar
ganz speziell möchte das am beispiel
dass der charta der digitalen
grundrechte der europäischen union tun
die sie auch im internet ganz einfacher
google können und da werden verschiedene
grundrechte eben im digitalen raum
formuliert und wir sollten diese
grundrechte mal kritisch betrachten und
dabei auch auf die diskussion dieser
grundrechte schauen die sie auch auf
dieser seite finden das heißt da gibt
immer auch eine diskussionsseite dazu
und dann mal schauen ob sich das deckt
mit unseren intuition ja dann danke ich
ihnen vielmals für die aufmerksamkeit
und wünschen allen frohe weihnachten